I've never been able
to found a single country in
the world where the policies
that have been advocated for
blacks in the United States
have lifted any people out of poverty.
I've seen many examples
around the world about
people began in poverty
and ended in affluence,
not one of them has
followed any pattern at all
like what is being advocated for blacks
in the United States.
That's the economist and
social critic Thomas Sowell
critiquing affirmative
action back in 1981.
In an age in which
espousing unpopular ideas
can destroy the careers of
journalists and academics.
Sowell's candor and insistence
on following the facts wherever they lead,
are more worthy of appreciation than ever.
Sowell was born in rural
North Carolina in 1930
to an uneducated family
without electricity
or running water.
He was orphaned and
raised by a great aunt.
When he was eight his
family moved to Harlem
and at one point he
was living in a shelter
for homeless boys keeping
a knife under his pillow
for protection.
He didn't finish college until he was 28
and went on to receive his PhD
from the University of Chicago
before he became
internationally celebrated
as an intellectual and writer.
His upbringing was more than
something to be overcome,
it profoundly shaped his scholarship.
In particular by making him disdainful
of elite intellectuals who
impose their ideas on society
through government.
As Sowell wrote in his memoir,
"Growing up he had daily
contact with people
who were neither well educated
nor particularly genteel,
but who had practical wisdom
far beyond what I had."
That gave him,
"A lasting respect for the
common sense of ordinary people,
a factor routinely ignored
by the intellectuals
among whom I would later make my career.
Sowell provocative body
of work on everything
from race to childhood development
to Charter Schools and Their Enemies,
is the subject of a new documentary
and a forthcoming biography
titled 'Maverick'.
He is someone who has been something
of an intellectual loner
throughout his career.
Jason Riley is a senior fellow
at the Manhattan Institute,
a columnist at the Wall Street
Journal and the author behind
the new documentary and
biography of Sowell.
Someone who has bucked convention,
concerned himself with
being a truth teller,
being a straight shooter.
Maybe this is a commentary
on intellectuals today
as that makes him a Maverick.
Someone who puts truth about popularity,
who doesn't concern himself
with being politically correct.
He follows the facts where they lead,
whether or not the
conclusion is a popular one.
Riley says that Sowell's genius rests
in his unwavering attention
to empirical facts and data
and policy outcomes
regardless of intentions.
A tendency that was
sharpened by his PhD training
at the University of Chicago
under future Nobel prize
winners Milton Friedman,
George Stigler and Friedrich Hayek.
This whole notion,
the black family has
always been disintegrating,
that is nonsense.
His studies goes up to 1925,
the great bulk of black families were
intact, two parent
families up through 1925
and going all the way back
through the era of slavery.
So it is now only within our own time
that we suddenly see
this inevitable tragedy
which the welfare system says
is gonna rush in to solve.
He was thinking like a Chicago economist.
Essentially it's an
adherence to empiricism,
to facts and logic and
putting that ahead of theory.
Thomas was much more interested
in how an idea has panned out.
What the evidence is
for success or failure
rather than simply what the intent is.
And I think that is what distinguishes him
and much of the Chicago school
from their counterparts at MIT
or Harvard or other places,
where there was much more of an emphasis,
at least in the field of economics,
on eloquent theories and mathematics.
When Sowell showed up
at the University of
Chicago for doctoral work,
he called himself a Marxist.
A designation he ultimately rejected
not because of Milton Friedman's lectures
but because of his
subsequent job experience
in the Federal government.
While I was still a Marxist,
I was taking Milton
Friedman's course, but I...
...
But one summer in the government
was enough to let me say,
"Now this government is
really not the answer."
I mean that is.
Milton Friedman didn't cure you
but the Federal government did.
In fact the Federal government did.
Never say the Federal
government doesn't do anything.
One of Sowell's most brilliant works
is 'Knowledge and Decisions'
published in 1980.
He elaborated on Austrian economist
Friedrich Hayek's insight that
information and knowledge
are disbursed among people
and markets in highly sophisticated
yet unarticulated ways.
That's something most
intellectuals and planners ignore
as they override the
expertise and experience
of the common man through government fiat.
In a 1981 review of the
book published in 'Reason',
Hayek wrote that Sowell had,
"...not only broadened the
application of the ideas
and effectively carried the
approach into new fields
that I never considered,
but he also succeeds
in translating abstract
and theoretical argument
into a highly concrete
and realistic discussion
of the central problems
of contemporary economic policy."
To the extent that decision making
is taken out of the
hands of ordinary people
and placed in the hands
of government bureaucrats
and politicians.
What you are doing is,
increasing the distance
between the person who makes the decision
and the person who has to
suffer the consequences
of that decision.
And one of the reasons Sowell
wrote that book is because
he thought that too much decision making
was being put in the hands of government
and that we were headed down a bad path,
by going in this direction.
And I think obviously he's
been borne out by that.
In 'A Conflict of Visions'
which is Sowell's
favorite of his own books,
he identified two fundamental modes
of understanding the world.
Thinkers ranging from Rousseau
to Marx to John Rawls,
exhibited what's Sowell
calls an unconstrained vision
based on the mistaken idea
that human beings and society
are perfectible.
In later books Sowell
championed a constrained vision
articulated by classical
liberals such as Adam Smith,
Edmund Burke and
America's founding fathers
who constructed a system
of checks and balances
to protect man from his worst tendencies.
The constrained vision rejects utopianism
and instead holds that social progress
comes from acknowledging that
there are no perfect
solutions, only trade offs.
As Burke wrote, "We cannot
change the Nature of things
and of men-but must act
upon them the best we can".
Sowell's good friend and
fellow amateur photographer,
Harvard linguist, Steven Pinker,
draws a parallel between how cameras work
and societies work.
Thomas commentated to me that,
to be a photographer, you
have to master trade offs.
All of the little adjustments
that you fiddle with in the camera,
never involve making everything
better everything worse,
it's a matter of trading
one thing off for another.
If you close down the diaphragm,
then you get lots and lots of
stuff in focus near to far.
On the other hand you're cutting
down the amount of light.
And a theme in Tom's work on society
is that all policies involve trade offs.
And Tom often loses patience at people
with sweeping visions, kere's
how we can improve society,
here's a solution to a problem.
And Tom points outs in
his political writings,
there are no solutions,
there are only trade offs.
Sowell's life experience
and ideological commitments
are perhaps most clear in
his long held positions
on the centrality of school choice
to improving the life
prospects for low income blacks
and other minorities.
One of his first major works was 1972's,
'Black Education Myths and Tragedies'
and his latest book, was 2020's,
'Charter Schools and Their Enemies'
I would allow their
parents to have a choice
of where to send them to school,
whether that choice is
called a voucher scheme,
open enrollment, tuition tax credit,
any kind of scheme of that sort,
that would put that power in
the hands of their parents.
Mainly because that would
mean that the schools
would have to be responsive to them.
As it is now the school is a monopoly.
They need not be responsive.
It is hard for me to understand
what harm is gonna be done
by allowing parents to have a choice
as compared to having self
interested bureaucrats
have a monopoly.
Tom brings this economic empiricism
to anything he's writing about.
That's something that
I've greatly appreciated
and then the need for,
to be a critical thinker,
in the way that he has.
He wrote about these racial topics
almost out of a sense of duty
because there were things
that needed to be said that too few others
were willing to say.
And I'm so glad he did his duty.
I think we are so much better off,
for having this body of
work out there to draw on,
that is still so relevant today.
If he had spent his entire
career writing about
intellectual history, Jean-Baptiste Say
and the classical liberals,
I'm sure he'd still be
remembered as a great scholar
but I am so glad he decided
to take the punches he's taken
over this other stuff on race
and ethnicity and culture.
Because I think for some of us,
that's equally important.
Despite disavowing utopianism
and human perfectibility,
Sowell has never wavered in a belief
that things can and should get better
if we put aside ideological priors,
assess the facts on the ground
and work to give individuals
more and better choices.
I grew up in an era when
people and particularly blacks,
were a lot poorer than today,
faced a lot more
discrimination than today.
And in which the teenage pregnancy rate
was a lot lower than today.
I don't believe there
is a predestined amount
of teenage pregnancy,
a predestined amount of husband desertion.
Today Sowell is in his 90s,
and still writing and publishing.
Though his greatest scholarship is almost
certainly behind him,
his body of work will continue
to have a profound impact
on our understanding of the
world, long after he's gone.